we've heard his arguments now we've seen
his evidence Prince Harry publicly
releasing private emails from those at
the heart of the late Queen's household
[Applause]
it was 2018 and Harry wanted an apology
over phone hacking from the Sun and News
of the World his emails show it's being
pursued by Buckingham Palace
on February the 1st he emailed Sally
Osman the late Queen's director of
communications asking for an update when
she replies there's been no response he
says the institution's looking
ineffective and weak ending there needs
to be an ultimatum otherwise this
institution and everything it stands for
becomes a laughing stock
a month later Sally Osman emails she has
the Queen's consent to use legal action
Her Majesty's approved the wording which
essentially says there's increasing
frustration at their lack of response
and engagement and while we've tried to
settle without involving lawyers we will
need to reconsider our stance unless we
receive a viable proposal
but nothing happens Harry claims a year
later his father takes a different
stance to the queen demanding he drop
his legal action to prioritize positive
stories about him and Camilla phone
hacking campaigners say it shows the
royal family scared of the tabloids it's
a blackmail plot essentially it says
listen we're going to tell your secrets
you either put up and shut up and do as
you're told or we're gonna we're gonna
publish what we like about you so
um I'm sure they would rather not be in
that Stranglehold Harry's evidence also
includes his mobile phone records which
he claims shows the repeated hacking of
his voicemail
[Music]
with just over a week until the
coronation this comes at a bad time for
the king and queen consort
they were lighting up Liverpool for
Eurovision
but with every Revelation Prince Harry
is exposing and proving just how far
he'll take his fight with the Press
Laura bundock Sky News